hi there steve here i'm in montreal
for the long fest festival day long i
arrived last night
today i want to talk about speaking from
day one
uh and what i really mean is starting to
speak early
and i'm talking about that for several
reasons
uh one reason is that
whereas i
normally wait until i have five thousand
ten thousand words at link before i have
my first online discussion
uh i mean in the case of russian i
waited a year and a half i think before
i started speaking czech i waited at
least six months and i thought i was
starting very early
and those are languages where the
writing system is not very difficult
with greek i started a little bit
earlier
and now with arabic i've had a few
discussions after 5 000 words and now
after 350 known words at link i've had
um two discussions
conversations that link with uh our
wonderful tutor rana
and so i want to explain that so one is
that i started speaking early and i'm
going to provide some background to that
and two
um there was a comment i think on um
on youtube here someone said you know i
have this tandem
uh relationship with someone where i
speak english or at least we exchange
russian for english and i have the
impression we're not making much
progress so i want to talk about
speaking and how i see it fitting into
the whole language learning process
bear in mind by the way i think benny
the irish polyglot is going to be here
uh and so i'm looking forward to meeting
with him and
in language learning there really is no
bad way
to learn different people like different
things and the important thing is to do
what you like doing so i talk about my
experience
i mean even last night at dinner with
some of the people participants we were
disagreeing on the importance of grammar
and how much grammar you can learn up
front and some people love grammar and
they think it's very logical and that
they need that in order to get into the
language and i of course prefer
to
get a lot of the language in me before i
try to
read any explanations of
what the language does i prefer to
experience the language first so there's
many different ways of doing things now
speak from day one why am i speaking so
early
uh in my learning insofar as farsi is
concerned
the biggest reason is that we don't have
text to speech at link
so because both arabic and farsi
uh with their script it's sometimes
difficult to know how to pronounce the
words
so with arabic i can click on and i can
hear it in text to speech
with farsi there is no text to speech so
what i do with my tutor
oh that's point number one at point
number two i think what has dramatically
changed in my language learning is the
many stories
the many stories
i believe dramatically sped up my
learning of greek
arabic and now farsi because the stories
contain
the most common verbs
they repeat the vocabulary and the
structures within each story three times
at least
and so we get a very very soon we get a
sense of word order we get a sense of
positive you know yes nose type
sentences questions
uh all of this kind of stuff that is
typically described in grammar
explanations through this repetitive
nature of the many stories you start to
get a feel of the language so i feel
that i'm progressing more quickly than
was the case when i was learning say
russian or czech we didn't have the many
stories so that's point number one
uh point number two
having the many stories now that i have
listened to
uh the top the first 10 minute stories
in farsi i've listened to 30 times
each one of them 25 to 35 times
that gives me something to take into my
conversation with my tutor even though i
only have 350 known words
i have listened to a limited number of
these stories
so many times that i'm in a position to
at least use that vocabulary to some
extent with mistakes and whatnot
so
you know i've got this concentrated
bit of the language that we can build
our conversation around and that makes
it a
pleasant experience obviously too if
we're on skype the connection has to be
good the person the tutor has to be
pleasant all of these things are
important
where the skype connection is poor uh
then it's very difficult to have a
lesson uh also
uh if if you go in there to have a
discussion and
every third word you don't understand
and then they so then i say how do you
say this and then the tutor explains it
and of course just by hearing it
especially with a poor connection makes
no impact on me whatsoever
if the tutor sends me a list of these
words later on i can review them but
with uh taking these sort of mini
stories then i've got a sort of a
concentrated dose of the language that i
can get into discussion around
the other thing we do
which is very valuable to me is that i
read the farsi out loud because it's not
like reading spanish or reading slovak
where
basically it's written the way it's
pronounced
uh for me to get used to the arabic
writing system and get to get used to
how these words are pronounced and so
forth i find it very useful to read
say the part one of one of these many
stories then we have a discussion around
that then we go on to another one we do
two stories per session so far
now
so to get from that so that's why i'm
starting early
uh would i start early on let's say if i
started learning turkish where the
apparently the the writing system is
very fanatic would i do the same i might
so then why why do i consider it useful
to speak
because
the speaking improves my
ability to focus on what i'm listening
to and reading so in other words
the goal of the
conversation is to improve the quality
of my listening and reading
because and i would take it even further
most of what i do
is
has the goal of making my listening more
valuable because i have more time
available to listen than anything else
in my car
doing the dishes and whatever so the
reading that i do the reviewing of words
and phrases talking to my tutor reading
again on the ipad or on the computer
it's all with the goal that when i am
listening
i'm able to write to derive the maximum
benefit out of it because listening is
the main sort of production engine
production end of my language learning
so
taking all of this now back to
this comment
here about how
you know language exchange wasn't
helping a lot
i believe that
you know speaking is going to help you
if you get a lot of it in other words if
you are immersed in the language and you
are every evening or three four hours a
day speaking in the language you're
getting so much input that you're going
to improve but if you are speaking three
times a week
on some kind of language exchange that
is not going to improve you very much
if it is
an incentive motivation
it heightens your your ability to
observe the language stimulates you all
of those things are good but then the
major learning activity in my mind is
still the listening and reading
and uh so this person for example who's
on a language exchange you know that can
be very motivating
uh i want to improve for the next time i
speak to rana in in farsi so it's it's
motivating but the the the place i'm
going to improve is through my reading
and listening and
you know review after each lesson of the
words and phrases that kind of activity
which i can organize easily i don't have
to set up on a you know a time slot for
it i just get in the car and it's on
it's it's always with me
and so that's where i learn
and the role of speaking
is to
create you know to improve the quality
of your input activity unless of course
you are surrounded by the language in
which case you are getting enough input
so speaking speaking early speaking a
little bit later it depends on your
situation depends on what you like to do
but to me it's still primarily to
improve the effectiveness of your input
learning activities
so and i will go and find benny and we
will disagree over this and it's
perfectly okay to disagree on anything
nowadays it's as if we have to persuade
everybody of everything we don't we can
have an opinion someone has a different
opinion we can exchange our views we're
stimulated we agree we disagree we maybe
move our views slightly it's all good
okay thank you for listening
bye for now
[Music]
you